hallo mein name ist flughafen meine
damen und herren wir spielen heute ein
spiel in dem ein meteorit auf die erde
fliegt und in 60 sekunden ein schlägt
man hat also noch eine minute zum leben
und mehr weiß ich noch nicht ich krieg
mal direkt auf stars der bildschirm wird
schwarz hier steht neuerdings also der
meteorit lädt jetzt der gleich auf die
erde fliegt im aktuellen nachrichten die
nasa hat soeben mitgeteilt dass ein
meteor gleich mit der erde kollidiert ok
scheiße erstaunlicherweise bleiben uns
nur noch 60 lebenszeit
was ist denn leben zahlt was habe ich da
gerade gesagt ich habe nur noch 60
sekunden verdammt ich wurde doch heute
erst zum nachrichtensprecher befördert
wird
könnt ihr nicht 60 sekunden vielleicht
ein bisschen besser deutsch lernen was
ist es wahr dass die erde zerstört wird
ich kann es nicht glauben was soll ich
damit den verdammten letzten 60 sekunden
des lebens anstellen kann ich jetzt
machen was ich will selbst wenn es
illegal ist wie wäre es wenn ich einen
apfelbaum pflanzen
ja denn ich nur noch eine minute zu
leben hätte würde ich auch erstmal
apfelbaum pflanzen verdammt noch mal ich
habe noch nicht einmal zeit darüber
nachzudenken los geht's okay wir sehen
hier oben haben noch 60 sekunden und co
entscheidend leute unsere zeit nicht ab
also sind wir unsterblich hiermit können
wir uns bewegen und laufen hiermit
können wir leute küssen hiermit können
wir leute gossen hier ist den
nachrichten
es ist ein
hier fahren da kann ich dann auch um
boxen um mein gott ich habe ein baseball
schläger wie will ich jetzt in der
u-bahn hier steht einfach eine frau
nackt rum die kürzlich jetzt auch mal
bis die audi gibt eine backpfeife
sie hat mich aus der u-bahn
rausgeschmissen lady du kriegst über dem
maul
er sehe durch die u bahn können aber
natürlich laufen hier die leute die sich
hier gekürzten hier kommen alle um
geboxt weiter geht's hier was das hier
ist das hier die nase oder das ist der
rakete ich glaube ich kann wegfliegen
mit der rakete was muss ich denn dafür
machen den typ küssen ja okay ich hab
den typ geküsst abend mit dem bug café
komm lass mich in die schweiz rakete die
gleichen
am
ich hab's vertagt wir fangen jetzt mal
von vorne an und laufen diesmal in die
andere richtung
ich muss mich jetzt mal ein bisschen
durchboxen jetzt bin ich hier in einem
park im hier ist ein hund den kann ich
auch boxen aber ich glaube da muss ich
mit liebe
doch nicht also da geht es ja auch rein
links aber keine ahnung muss ich hier
vielleicht ein paar leute erst mal alle
abknutschen oder so die freuen sich alle
er hier freut sich auch der freut sich
auch hier das pärchen wenn ich die kürze
die frauen einig die freundin geschlagen
haben der hund mich nicht reinlassen
wenn ich ihnen hier ganz nett küsse denn
hier den hund am boxen ich glaube ich
brauche den baseballschläger zu den hund
also ab zurückgelaufen zu ihm hier so
zaki baseball-schläger mitnehmen den
habe ich jetzt jetzt zurück zum hund ich
habe noch drei sekunden alter das muss
doch schaffen sonst sagt oh mein gott
ich kann reinen frau
aber da geht's auf jeden fall noch
weiter also gehen wir diesmal direkt zu
diesem footballspieler hier genau gibt
uns dass wir zurück
wahrscheinlich haben die beim football
baseball schläger oder luca und jetzt ab
durch den park hin zu dem hund soll du
gehst weg ich gehe hier vorne rein und
jetzt sehen wir schon sind hier sind
leute mit waffen um ein gott okay ich
war jetzt in die leute habt was das denn
du hast einen nuklearen finger klicken
zum benutzen wenn paar sekunden später
[Musik]
schlussendlich ich bin tot es war ein
gutes leben wahnsinn luca ich dachte
vielleicht dass diese rakete auf dem
meteor gelenkt werden kann aber nein sie
ist direkt zurück zur erde geflogen was
ich jetzt mal machen wollte war er den
hund hier zu kürzen vielleicht kann ich
dann mit dem hier irgendwie
zusammenlaufen ok laut zumindest mit mir
wird auch mein gott was ist denn wenn
ich mit dem hund jetzt zu dem anderen
umgehen also ich gehe hier rüber da ist
der böse wohnt unter rechts kommt jetzt
der liebe und gab
ja
die beiden sind zusammen ich kann euch
auch küssen kann ich dir noch boxen kann
ich nicht aber jetzt kann ich auch
wieder hier rein laufen und habe mir
auch wieder seine waffe können
genau jetzt habe ich die waffe viel mehr
passierte ich hier aber gerade nicht was
habe ich wieder
durch die waffe gegen den
baseballschläger getauscht sich
vollidiot also ich habe jetzt wieder den
nuklear empfänger ich werde ihnen jetzt
nicht hier drinnen zünden sondern so
weit wie ich komme also ich hab noch
drei sekunden werden jetzt direkt vor
meinem haus setzen und zwar hier hin
vielleicht schießt die rakete jetzt
genau wieder werde es muss doch
irgendeine möglichkeit geben das level
zu schaffen also ich bin jetzt direkt
hier durchgegangen
können wir jetzt von ihm schnell die
waffe im damit ich das beste direkt
schon mal habe jetzt fahre ich das ding
mal aufnehmen dieses teil hier mit weil
vielleicht muss ich damit jetzt zu
diesem nasa ding da hinten gehen
das heißt erstmal bereich den typen hier
weg jetzt ab durch die u-bahn ich kann
ja auch ein paar leute um ball an ich
mein ich habe ihn noch 60 sekunden zum
leben jetzt bin ich hier hinten weil er
die leute um und bin jetzt auch hier und
werde nun weiter komme ich nicht oder
nee wetter komme ich stelle jetzt hier
dieses teil hin aber
die rakete fliegt und sie fit auch
wieder runter wie kann ich das denn
retten also ganz schnell hier hinter dem
nuklear empfänger geholt jetzt ganz ganz
schnell wieder hierhin zurück laufen
nämlich glaubt die ganzen leute die hier
so rumlaufen die sehen alle relativ
unnütz hier weiter durch hier ist auch
nichts niemand besonderes jetzt hier
durch die ballade ohne dich vielleicht
auch um jetzt hier
oh mein gott ich finde der rakete leute
ich hab sogar noch 17 sekunden
oh mein gott wer ist der meteorit bin
jetzt hier wieder auf dem level was muss
jetzt jemand ich glaube hier muss ich
jetzt das teil aufstellen oh mein gott
wenn das klappt
ok oh mein gott oh mein gott ich habe es
geschafft ich habe es geschafft
schlussendlich ich bin ich habe die
musik stirbt man da so oder so versteht
das jetzt falsch ich werde das ganze
jetzt noch mal ein bisschen anders
machen hier ist der nachrichtensprecher
den hab ich jetzt mal geküsst er sagt
aber gar nichts hier von ihm kann ich
mir auch ein baseballschläger können mit
dem baseballschläger kann ich auch den
hier umbauen
genau hier noch ein baseballschläger da
ist die tante wie kann ich mich nicht
klären es gibt die mir eine backpfeife
das pärchen hier kann ich umhauen
hier ist noch von schulmädchen aber mit
der kann ja auch nix machen hier vorne
ist ja nur die nasa und so hier komme
ich nicht durch der der mensch
schutzschild was ist wenn ich die küsse
aber er lässt mich auch nicht durch also
ich glaube so wie ich das gespielt habe
also erst mal dieses nuklear ding holen
und dann den nasa menschen abknallen und
dann in die rakete setzen
das ist schon richtig ich bring doch
gerade einfach jeden um hier habe ich
ein taxi nehmen ja das taxi kann ich
sogar auch zu hauen
hier vorne den typen die jetzt ein
nachrichtensprecher wieder der sich von
aufgezogen hat du kriegst auch noch eins
über die rübe okay die zeit wieder um
ja und jetzt sind wir wieder tot ich den
meteoriten die sache ist allerdings noch
kein mal ihr alles durchgelesen wenn wir
sterben nämlich sehr eine weiße
landschaft was soll das sein der himmel
ist es dass du bist fertig wach bitte
auf wo bin ich
wir kriegen unsere maske ab wir haben
soeben einen persönlichkeitstest mit
ihnen durchgeführt
fanden sich in einer virtuellen realität
deinen scheiß ernst alter ich will die
welt retten und avaya virtual reality
virtuelle realität also wurde die erde
gar nicht zerstört das ist richtig
unsere neueste technologie ist wie aus
dem film matrix sie ermöglicht ihnen ein
virtuelles leben in kurzer zeit zu
erleben durch die analyse ihres
verhaltens können wir präzise
rückschlüsse auf ihren charakter ziehen
eigentlich sollte ich dir auch sagen
deine familie diesen test auf dem
bildschirm verfolgt
oh mein sohn ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass du einer von der sorte bist du bist
abschauen wie kannst du dich selbst noch
menschen nennen gehst du ein psychopath
ich kann es nicht fassen dass du heute
getötet hat ich denke wir sollten uns
trennen
warum hast du gedacht hast du menschen
getötet hat hat jeder spaß gemacht hier
sind spaß die alter ich möchte so ein
cooler mörder zeichen wie du wenn ich
groß bin okay aber mehr kann ich dagegen
die machen
ich kann hier noch auf deine liste
klicken und dann sehen wir schon die
drei sachen haben wir beziehungsweise
willst einen hinweis das ergebnis von
rom verhalten
du kannst eine atombombe beim
nuklearanlage am besten bekommen die
bulldogge kannst ablenken ok ich glaube
das sind sachen die ich schon geschafft
habe wenn du ein held bist solltest du
niemanden opfern während du die welt
rettet ist okay also da steht man kann
das ganze level auch abschließen wenn
man einfach nur freundlich ist also ich
habe jetzt hier den hund geküsst hier
dem baseballschläger bekommen die
mülltonne muss ich ja umhauen kann ich
dann ja auch noch küssen die beiden
hunde hier sind wieder in love mit dem
baseballschläger kann ich auch das ding
hier aufbauen da muss ich ja nicht
unbedingt die waffe am start haben genau
das hab ich den nuklear empfänger und
jetzt ab hier nach hinten durch ich bin
zu fuß schneller als die fahrradfahrer
und hinten ist jetzt die polizei
das teil muss ich ja weg hauen aber der
hier er lässt mich nicht vorbei der
lässt mich der lässt wenig vorbei den
muss ich wecken was ist wenn ich hier
dieses nuklear dinge hin setze ich
glaube dann passiert das gleiche wie
vorhin auch dass die rakete nämlich hoch
fliegt und wieder runter auf die erde
hey wie soll ich das denn hinkriegen
ohne gewalt ich hab da ein bisschen
herumprobiert und dabei entdeckte dass
wenn ich die mädels eine backpfeife gebe
und sie dementsprechend hinter mir her
läuft das wenn ich dann bei der nasa
angekommen bin dass sie sich dann für
den typen interessiert und man dort dann
quasi keine gewalt anwenden muss also
ich hab den nuklearen finger und sie
muss ich jetzt küssen er nicht ich muss
sie kürzen genau sie läuft mir jetzt
hinterher das heißt ich gehe jetzt hier
vorne hinhaut dass hier eben weg das
heißt dass die dame wenn sie an kommt
direkt mit ihm dann hallo du musst
wissen bei allen hier kommen immer zehn
sekunden die beiden geht am um titeln
sorgen auch ich gehen die rakete das ist
nicht wahr
nein ich wusste nur noch auf den knopf
drücken
privat ist mir scheißegal das ganze ist
eine kag simulation von irgendwem doktor
also darum bemühe ich mich da überhaupt
an der stelle mich das heutige video
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
das gerne mal einen daumen hoch bei
diesem video dann schreibt mir unten in
die kommentare was ihr machen würdet
wenn ihr jetzt nur noch 60 sekunden zeit
hätte um zu leben
[Musik]